grammarians we're going to talk about
relative pronouns today and what
relative pronouns do is they link
clauses together specifically
independent and dependent clauses and if
you don't know what independent and
dependent clauses are that's okay just
suffice it to say that these pronouns
allow you to staple phrases together for
example in the sentence the man who sold
the world is coming by on Tuesday the
pronoun who is the relative pronoun
there it's linking the independent
clause the man is coming by on Tuesday
to the dependent clause sold the world
the relative pronouns of English are who
whom who's that and which and we use
them all for different things so we can
use who whom whose and that to refer to
people and we can use who's that and
which to refer to things let me show you
you could say the salad that I bought
was wilted but at the same time I can
also use that in this sentence the man
that I saw smiled see I'm using that to
refer to him I could also use who but
the word which however does not play
very nicely with people in the sentence
the witch who cast the spell is kind we
could use either the witch who cast the
spell of the witch that cast the spell
because I both that and who work with
people but which strangely does not so
we couldn't say for example the witch
which owns a cat is cruel that's just
not how the language shook out which is
not a relative pronoun that applies to
people these are the relative pronouns
of English this is broadly how they work
and I'm going to get into more specifics
in following videos you can learn
anything Dave it out